this year's five nominees for Best
Director come from three different
continents
they include Academy veterans and
first-timers their projects ranged from
a low-budget movie shot in 27 days in an
epic that took several years to complete
but as different as they are they all
share one thing in common an incredible
talent for filmmaking the nominees for
achievement in directing are for City of
God
Fernando Morales for Lord of the Rings
Return of the King Peter Jackson for
lost in translation
Sofia Coppola
for Master and Commander the far side of
the world Peter Weir for Mystic River
clint eastwood and the Oscar goes to
Peter Jackson love the Rings
this is the second Academy Award tonight
for Peter Jackson including his
nomination this year for Best Motion
Picture an adapted screenplay for the
Lord of the Rings The Return of the game
this is his eighth nomination
thank you Wow look thank you so much for
the Academy and for all our yeah you're
giving us an incredibly overwhelming
night and I we just appreciate it so
much Bob Shaye and Michael then God you
did the most risky thing that I think
anyone has ever done in this industry
and I'm so happy for you that it paid
off your collaboration and your
partnership and your support just gave
me the most incredible working
experience of my life
- Barry Osbourne our producer thank you
so much Barry for just being there every
day and supporting us - a wonderful cast
a wonderful crew in New Zealand
everybody that made my working day so
enjoyable it was just there when I
needed it to be there and the actors
were just doing such a wonderful job and
I just want to thank two very special
people that when I was 8 years old I
made films at home on a super 8 camera
that my mum and dad had bought for me
and they supported me all through the
years and they died in the last few
years they didn't see these films made
so for Bill and Joan thank you
you